lizzo this guy Mike what's the deal are
you in love with this guy are you out of
love with this guy where is your
romantic life right now so men out there
know whether they should waste their
time going after you listen don't waste
your time honey I am very much in love
and with Mike Mike absolutely 100 is
this the real deal now and what was
going on in the past so in the past we
were friends I had a lot of [ __ ] to do
and I was still very much in my I feel
unlovable place and I still was very
much not where I wanted to be
career-wise and I have always since I
was like a teenager put my career in
front of any relationship any person so
even if a person came around that I was
googly Gaga about I had these wild
defenses up that made it almost
impossible for a true intimate
relationship to occur it was all very
surface but the with anyone with him it
was different because if he loved
something and you let it you let it go
and if it's meant to be it comes back to
you and we both let it go because we
both had a lot going on in our lives
um and then when the time was right we
came together
and we just recently were like oh we
together we this is official because I'm
very for I'm very like traditional about
certain things like we need to have the
talk it needs to be like discussed and
um anything before that is just
we just in the playing field you know
but we're not playing any games with
each other anymore we're very much
locked in you will marry Mike do you
believe and have children with Mike
there's nobody else I'm gonna be with
for the rest of my life
oh
foreign